[Music]
hey what's up guys and welcome back to
hot ones you're probably confused you
are watching first week feast today
we're joined by andrew ray you know him
from his extremely popular cooking
channel binging with babish binging with
bad [ __ ] in the
building yeah let's let's break the
internet
here's to you the internet
you're why this is happening
today my friend and youtube cooking star
binging with babish is here in my
restaurant to see if he can survive a
shift working on the line a lot of
people when they email me or when they
when they meet me on the street or
whatever they say
thanks chef or good job chef and i'm
like i didn't earn that title you know
i've never watched i've never worked in
a restaurant today's the day are you
ready
yes
there's 15 minutes
before service you have 10 minutes to
patty out four ounce patties
great tomatoes that's the way i do it
and slice onions
are you ready for this yes chef one two
three go
oh
ten minutes i got my timer right here
let's go i should pick up
one of your balls and it should weigh
exactly four ounces you can trust my
balls
oh boom
yeah first the walk-in and now this
what's next
all right i'm gonna step it up one more
time all right
all right get two more buns let's cut it
two more burgers are ordered in all
right
two burgers yes chef uh yes sir
yes father
bam
that's right
okay here we go come on
[Music]
oh
my boy's got it
beautiful
there now you now just go all the way
through
perfect okay well
now we go
you you're getting a rest
there you go
oh
did we get that
so today is all about pineapple on pizza
[Music]
see that's what's going to ask you why
do you think it's so controversial well
i have a few theories on that it's
because it's gross it's disgusting it's
gnarly it's ugly uh and i don't like it
that being said i'm a strict libertarian
about pizza toppings whatever you put on
your pizza is your business
and i will fight to the death for your
right to do it and so in my mind because
i don't like pineapple and pizza the
only way to make pineapple on pizza work
was to make a pizza that isn't really
pizza
what makes it not pizza what do you mean
well it's more of a taco it is an al
pastor pork pizza pork that i'm going to
shove into the shape of a taco so i'm
going to start uh doing this thing oh
it's fighting me oh look at listen all
the bubs though you hear that
i need to get glasses with pads on them
these guys slip down every time i have
to use my hand
so
those are expensive i've got my pizza
dough stretched out yes looking good
saved a little bit of that uh that pork
marinade oh wow so use that as my base
base sauce just enough to remind you
that it's technically a pizza
now i'm going to lay down my oaxaca
cheese
block of cheese being the mexican string
cheese that i love more than any other
cheese question mark and then i've got
my
al pastor pork i almost forgot the most
important ingredient pineapple goes down
i am quite a fan of pineapple not on
pizza okay but on alpaca store which is
what this is
i'm going to throw this in give it some
blast and heat and as i always say
whenever i put something in the oven
let's see what happens
you might have noticed i didn't slice
the pizza well let me tell you why i
didn't slice the pizza because there's
only one way to eat an al pastor taco
pizza it's a taco pizza
all right oh
this is brilliant
so we've done the shake shack we've done
the in and out let's just put it
together and make some in and out shake
shack babies you're a madman let's break
the internet let's put damn it
babish style
[Music]
[Applause]
that's the best sound in the world
yeah
to animals style it up let's get some
mustard on that bad boy
[Music]
[Applause]
cheese them up cheese them up you start
to see the caramelization on that
mustard man
love this on the in-n-out burger
extra sauce extra spread
veg on the bottom
i think these are the most beautiful
burgers
oh yeah in the world
we literally squashed east coast west
coast beef here today in this kitchen
unity all right time to eat let's give
it a shot
oh yeah
dude
that's a good that was a good bird
that's a marriage made in heaven see
that's what happens when people put
aside their differences and just get
along
cheers
all right andrew rae here we are at the
end of our spicy chicken wing journey
long overdue if you ask me and i think
it's been so special that we should
immortalize it forever and ever
here's to you the internet
you're why this is happening you lean a
little closer
[Music]
this ain't my first radio
oh papa
the bomb is sadistic that stuff just
wants to hurt you it's like a it's like
a mac 10 or pornography there's no
artistic value to it
i have to cough really bad but go ahead
holy [ __ ] time flies when you're having
fun
here
have some
have some of the real stuff i'll chase
it there you go yeah chase that milk
with whiskey
like men do
as men do
look i can make it squawk
thank you so much for having me sean
so there you have it folks some obvious
choices some controversial picks and a
whole lot of fun
you showed your chops cheers you did you
did a great job and i'm glad that you
that i was the first person you did that
with it was a lot of fun awesome man i'm
glad to have you
clean this shot
yes chef
you